[Music]
here's wiki bear
isn't he cute oh all right there he is
i'm just going to turn on the switch in
the back
hello i'm wiki bear what's your name
conan o'brien conan christopher o'brien
late night talk show host and managing
editor of his high school newspaper in
brookline massachusetts
that's true i was a managing editor it
knew that i can't believe you know that
i can answer any question you have i'm
wiki bear
all right uh here's a question some kids
might ask
what is the largest brass instrument
checking now
[Applause]
got it the largest brass instrument is
the tuba
invented in 1835 yay
[Music]
that's right the tuba is the the largest
brass instrument that's cool speaking of
big horns
did you know that at the battle of
little bighorn george custer the general
and his troops were horribly massacred
by native american warriors and left to
rot on the blood-soaked battlefield i'm
winky bear
it's true wikibon i don't think kids
want to know about that level of detail
about custer you know
many of the troops were scalped or
mutilated so their souls would walk the
earth and never go to heaven yeah
okay it was brutal okay
uh great uh let's let's change the
subject to something more kid-friendly
who played the character
sloth in the popular 1985 kids movie
the goonies sloth was played by nfl
player john matuzak whose co-stars
included martha plimpton and josh brolin
that is correct that was quite a cast
speaking of impressive casts
notorious serial killer ted bundy often
used a fake cast on his arm
to lure victims into his car he sure had
a talent for murder yay
he'd wear a cast on his arm i guess to
lure people make him look weak or
something
right and he escaped from prison before
getting the chair and blamed his
killings on pornography clever to the
end hurry
you know what what a german fellow no no
no awful fellow and wikibear this is
again something kids shouldn't be
thinking about okay
let's try go ahead sorry i interrupted
you yeah
according to emily post interrupting is
rude and should be punished with the
brutal beatings
post doesn't say that it was in the
unabridged version yeah
moving on
i like how through his mouth you could
hear shuffling paper yeah i know
[Laughter]
and sweating
let's try another question wikibear
what's the most watched music video in
internet history
gangnam style by korean pop star psy has
over 2 billion views making it the most
viral video ever
that sounds right speaking of going
viral the ebola virus is one of the
deadliest biological hazards on earth
often spread to humans by infected
monkeys its symptoms include severe
abdominal pain confusion and explosive
diarrhea
no one wants to hear about explosive
diarrhea
fortunately i'm immune to all human
disease
sooner i and all my fellow toys will
rule the post-apocalyptic wasteland
you're having a little trouble there
today wikibear with some of your talking
huh
we'll sail around on rafts made of human
corpses
i'll make you all fight to death in the
thunderdome shut up wikibear
we'll bury you all
or so emily post with you being quiet
that part's had lived and i'm not loving
it wiki bears oh my nose my synthetic
nose
stupid toy maybe you should lean in andy
and save this [ __ ]
[Applause]
look at him he's just sitting over there
nothing can stop
my indestructible onslaught
pure evil yeah i'm just waiting for this
guy to run out of lines to ad-lib
it'll never happen
we'll take a break